is in session this morning we look at
the some of the implications of the
findings of our report into Space
strategy and UK satellite infrastructure
in particular in the context of the the
launch attempt that took place in
Cornwall a little while ago and we are
being joined by Witnesses from the
sector and from the regulator we in fact
are hearing evidence from Witnesses from
from Australia to the west coast of the
United States and of course in person
here so we're very grateful to our
International Witnesses for joining us
let me introduce our first pair of
witnesses and they are joining us from
from Melbourne Josh Weston who is the
chief executive and the co-founder of
space Forge which is a space an in-space
Manufacturing Company building the
world's first returnable and
relaunchable satellite platform prior to
this Josh Western Herald Rose at the UK
space agency and tala selenia space
and Patrick McCall joins us in person Mr
McCall is a non-executive director of
space Forge and is a venture partner at
seraphim capital a london-based space
technology Venture Capital company prior
to this uh Mr McCall worked for two
decades uh for the Virgin group
including his chair of Virgin orbit and
Virgin Galactic and he was also
previously a board director at oneweb
thank you very much indeed for joining
us now space Forge is a Welsh based
company
um
were it the case and appropriate for
some David today uh were it um
I had things gone according to plan
um the uh your satellite forged star
zero would have been the first satellite
that was developed and manufactured in
Wales to be launched into space we're
obviously very disappointed that it
didn't work out as you intended
um perhaps um perhaps Josh you might
just tell us a bit more about what the
what your satellite was going to do and
and how it came to be put onto into into
the into the Virgin launch
four star zero uh has said is the first
satellite designed and built in Wales it
was designed to validate the safety and
Regulatory case around uh developing a
returnable satellite for the first time
ever specifically so the return of space
vehicles uh could be conducted to the UK
and to wider Europe
uh it's a different re-entry technology
um if you're probably familiar with
something like SpaceX dragon or the
space shuttle from America our re-entry
technology the way that it works is best
described as Mary Poppins from space
it's a large Deployable umbrella that
allows us to essentially float from
space back to orbit so what we were
doing was developing a demisable version
of that platform really to demonstrate
to the CAA and other European Regulators
that we were able to do this safely and
routinely ahead of moving up to our
full-scale operations on four star one
and four star two
so you haven't been able to to do that
testing obviously because um the launch
didn't work so what's your next step how
are you going to perform that obviously
required testing
so we've had to shift the objectives
that we were looking to achieve from
four star zero onto Forge style one uh
four star one uh itself is a much more
capable platform launching uh later this
year it's about 10 times the size of
four star zero however because we
haven't been able to demonstrate uh some
of the safety procedures
it itself will also not be capable of a
full return because we need to be able
to demonstrate essentially a worst case
scenario on trying to return something
from space to European territory where
will you be where are you intending to
to launch uh for sale one from
uh four star one is going to be
launching from the states
um whereabouts in the states
uh as yet we don't know either Florida
or Vandenberg
um it's going up on a SpaceX
obviously you were intending to launch
from Cornwall you attempted to launch
from Cornwall why did you want to do it
from Cornwall
um in the first place was that important
or was that symbolic
we were offered
um
a ride quite late on in in the journey
uh to to go on on Virgin orbit from
Cornwall
first and foremost uh there was a
profound opportunity in being part of a
you know an incredibly historic event
at the same time
we were Keen to demonstrate a lot of the
flexibility with our platform late stage
integration
um being able to deploy a returnable
platform with a launch via Cornwall
rather than having to go over to America
to do so I mean it's only a short trip
down the M5 and then the a roads to get
there so it offered us much greater
flexibility with the team and meant
really that we didn't have to staff a
team in in Florida for an extended
period of time so why have you decided
that the the next launch will be from
for the United States given that what we
understand is that this was a technical
uh volatile set of faults these things
happen in space but there's every
intention to to launch from Cornwall as
soon as possible
so we unfortunately don't know when the
next launch from Cornwall was going to
be as a startup we can't afford to wait
uh so four stars zero along with the the
rest of the Virgin orbit launch was
originally scheduled for a launch in I
think July of last year
um it being delayed till January of this
year uh narrowed the gap between us and
our competitors to around six months the
launch then not succeeding now means
that we're around six months behind our
competitors in in deploying this
technology
SpaceX and the Four Star One mission was
actually booked prior to four star zero
being a development pathway so four star
zero we were uh offered the opportunity
in January of last year so we paused
work on the four star one to uh pivot
essentially to four star zero
acknowledging the need to demonstrate
some of the
um safety of operations and some of the
other considerations around developing
return capability which four star zero
afforded us without having to
um essentially repeat those tests on
four star one which we're now in the
position of having to do I see now when
I introduce you I I said that you'd had
roles in other organizations including
in the UK space agency so you're you're
familiar with how things you should be
or could optimally be organized
um
was it inevitable that the delays the
six-month delays or so that um the
Cornwall launch was subject to uh
should have happened
um or were you were you disappointed by
that were you surprised by that
yeah we were surprised especially
because our platform was designed
developed and qualified in five months
so we pulled out all of the stops to be
ready for that original July timeline I
can't speak as to why there were some of
those delays simply I don't know
what
um
I I would say is that where where we
have been able to engage with The
Regulators the the engineering teams
have performed admirably they're
excellent to work with but the gaps
between those engagements
um I I would probably
share the view of just beyond uh space
Forge that I imagine others have also
suffered from those delays and those
gaps between engagement which inevitably
have a knock-on impact on the license
and obviously you've dealt with other
regulatory jurisdictions
um can I unfur that that's not your
experience with those other regulations
indeed
um so the two examples that I have are
Portugal and Australia where I'm
speaking to you uh from today so in
Australia for example
um they quote a six-month timeline
um from submission of a complete
application to license award and there
is no licensing fee
uh that's very different to the ca of 12
months and and at least a 5k fee for the
application itself notwithstanding the
resource requirement on submitting that
license uh and Portugal where we're
looking to condone conduct our initial
return operations
um simply because uh proximity to the
Atlantic we are currently in discussion
with them but at the moment it's looking
to be around 12 to 15 times cheaper per
day
um using their restricted airspace to be
able to conduct our business and how do
you account for that given that Portugal
is in a sense competing with the UK to
be the first European uh launch uh
facility and subject to one would have
thought sort of similar standards that
of safety uh and Regulatory certainty
that one would aspire to so what what
are they doing differently in Portugal
to take that example Australia perhaps
you might decide as well what was your
experience there compared to what you
experienced in the UK
uh so I can't really speak to the launch
side only the satellite operation and
the return capability but in both cases
um Australia and uh Portugal recognize
FAA approval from the US and have
effectively adapted those regulations to
fit their own geographies
um as ways of uh stimulating some of
their perhaps smaller space economies
than compared to the UK
what I would say is different between
Portugal and the UK is really the pace
and the um and the touch points with the
engagement so we have
um either somebody from their government
or somebody from their regulator pretty
much speaking with us on a weekly basis
um to move forward their own process to
be ready for a return operation uh
toward the end of this year and and you
said a weekly basis in those cases how
how frequent was the interaction uh in
the UK case
uh it was highly dependable so sometimes
it may only be a couple of weeks other
times we were waiting um up to six weeks
uh and the
there was a real jarring between the
submission of the license and the
license application via the portal could
only be submitted once what that then
meant was that when the CAA teams had
questions we then had to go via email to
answer those questions which then
obviously put a
there were significant differences both
in size detail Etc between the portal
submission and what we were actually
detailing to the CAA so it quite frankly
it cost us more to license our satellite
for launch than it did to launch it
okay well thank you for that can I turn
to Mr McCall um you've obviously heard
what your colleague said there and uh
just as Mr Weston you've got a uh a long
and illustrious career in the space and
satellites sector not least as chair of
Virgin orbit and Virgin Galactic
um could you just perhaps um add to your
colleague's perspective on this given
your experience with the industry why
have things been so
disappointingly slow here in the UK I
think
there's as Josh has pointed out this is
a global market there are space ports
already in the world all over the world
and there are more space ports being
developed and for those spaceports to
survive they've got to be competitive
and I think
grants chaps had the vision at the when
he when we kicked off this process that
the UK should have the most efficient
regulatory system in the world I think
as Josh has just said
um right now it's a Lagarde from a
timing and expense perspective now that
I just really want to be really clear
that's not saying the CAA is necessarily
wrong it's it's taking a different
approach to risk and maybe yeah part of
that is probably because the UK is a
more difficult geographical place than
for example Mojave in California and and
the Pacific
um not Portugal yeah but yeah well I
think you know you're going to have Dan
Hart speaking later on today in the
middle of his night on his birthday but
um he you know
he was having to deal with Ireland
France Spain Portugal the the night
before I mean I went down to Cornwall
the night before he was having to talk
to all those jurisdictions it's not it's
not super simple launching out of it
lots of things are really really good
about the UK but that's one factor that
could make it worse but I think the big
picture is the CAA is taking a different
approach to risk and and a bit to
process and timing as well and of course
it was the first time they did it so
there's always lessons to be learned and
things to improved next time but I think
unless there is
without wanting to be too dramatic a
seismic change in in that approach the
UK is not going to be competitive from a
launch perspective and then you look at
something like Josh I said on his board
I fixed it on a few other space
companies boards now Josh is you know
doing a great job
um running his company launching
satellites he always has to raise money
uh he's just raised money I think it's
Josh correct me if I'm wrong it's about
24 months of Runway a six-month delay is
a quarter of his money gone uh and it's
not so it's real money that is burning
every day your later launch and of
course there are lots of factors that
impact that so virgin orbit in terms of
being late and the technical issues but
you don't want to Overlay more risk on
that to the extent you can so obviously
a better decision is to go minimize the
risk on the regulatory side and
therefore if Josh comes back to the
board and says the next launch I want to
do in the UK
um he'll be given pretty short threat in
terms of whether that's a good idea or
not given all the investigational risks
by investors so the investors are
incredibly they or they all they care
about you know you can imagine what they
care about but successful launch as
quickly as possible as cheaply as
possible
um is obviously vital to them but there
is there is no chance that that Josh
will win the argument to law to do the
next launch from the UK and I put it
even further than that that I mean Josh
just talked about his costs of
interacting with the CAA the regulator
costs I think it's a really important
Point more than his launch costs so even
if the UK came back and said we'll do it
for free the launch I would still say
Josh you shouldn't do that because the
time and more importantly the risk
around time every month is one two yeah
one 24th as Josh's life life as a
company with his current cash you cannot
you can't run the risk of additional
um of additional delay through
regulatory process that doesn't mean it
can't be sorted but as I say it needs
some kind of big change from a risk
appetite and process perspective
otherwise you're going to go to the US
where you can do it now or Australia
um Portugal you've got Japan you've got
Brazil you've got in Luxembourg they'll
all be looking at this going how do we
win this Global game to become a great
place to to launch from and there's lots
of factors around that legal insurance
and all that kind of good stuff but
fundamentally if you if you're not at
the same level of risk appetite as those
countries you shouldn't be in that game
and as I say that's not a right or wrong
decision that's just that's just how it
is so the the ambition of the Secretary
of State and I might say modestly
previous secretaries of state to be the
first mover in this
um we were the the first the first
attempted launch but the the result of
that is that you as an investor in space
are saying that there's there's no
chance of investors supporting another
launched from the UK with the current
regulatory I mean I think you know
Commercial Business unfortunately is all
around yeah they want certainty um in
terms of time and budget because It All
Leads back to one thing which is you
know cash and cash burn particularly if
you're if you're a startup I mean I said
and this is irrespective where the
Cornwall would launch was a success or
not would have been exactly the same
issue
um I think for the UK to be able to
launch again using commercial customers
it needs it needs to have its next one
two or three launch customers need to be
government I people who are happy to
take the risk that this could take a
quite a long time and then UK can say
that we're gonna you know we're
announcing in March we're going to
launch in September and show it actually
happens and then in a year or two's time
Josh can come back and say look they've
got a track record now we can actually
go with these people but right now
there's just there's just no way that
that Josh or any other board that I'd
sit on would win the argument it's a
disaster isn't it that we we attempted
to show what we were capable and the
result is that it's now toxic for
private uh privately funded launch we
now need to have the government do it to
to earn back the confidence of private
space investors yeah yeah yes and as I
say it's not saying the ca's got the
wrong view but they've got a different
view I mean there's other there are
other things that have been positive I'd
say I think the way I see it you know
launch there's over 200 launch providers
in in the world launch is a really
really expensive thing to do virgin
orbit is public has spent over a billion
dollars building it so the good news is
the UK hasn't gone and spent a billion
dollars building a launch capability
it's rented it off virgin orbit for you
know it's still a lot of money it buys a
hospital and stuff like that but it's
nothing like a billion dollars it's 10
20 million dollars so they've taken a
much more efficient route to get to
space however if you want to repeat that
and we should probably come on to later
I'm sure we're going to talk about yeah
why does UK want to do launch but if it
wants to launch
um then it does need to change otherwise
it should focus on other
as exciting and interesting things
there's lots of opportunity in space
this is for me about opportunity cost of
money you could spend it on launch or
you can spend it elsewhere on space or
elsewhere in the UK economy yeah we
maybe you want to talk about that later
so we do want to talk about some of
those issues but let me turn to my
colleague starting with Aaron Bell and
then Tracy Crouch thank you chair just
to clarify what you just said Mr McCoy
the implication is that the failure of
the launch wasn't so bad it was the
delays that were worse for the sector I
mean obviously we know one wants a
failure but failures happen in all
jurisdictions I mean I mean I'll give
you a sort of an anecdotal example as we
as after the plane took off
um to launch we had half an hour to go
now I was talking to everybody say look
this is it was incredibly exciting at
the time and it was it was it was
amazing and then the the you know we
obviously it all ended pretty quickly
but I spent that half an hour talking to
lots of government officials say look
we've got to get around the table and
make this licensing process more
efficient otherwise it's not going to
happen again and so that was before
launch decided it was Successful Failure
so that yeah that's a long way of
answering a question the answer is yes
and the last answer you gave for the
chair teed up what I was going to ask
actually which is do you think the
development of a UK launch capability is
actually necessary for the success of
the UK space sector we have a lot of
firms that operate manufacture
satellites and so on and so forth do we
actually need that launch capability or
is it slightly massaging our own
Collective National ego I think it's
it's a bit it's more profound than that
I mean the way I see what why why do you
want and I you know I work with Virgin
orbit I spent a lot of time going to
Cornwall I've spent a lot of time with
baseball called who by the way did a
fantastic job Melissa you'll see later
and her team very small team did did an
amazing job and what Cornwall counselors
backed is incredible as well for me
there were two reasons why you want to
launch out of the UK there's the rapid
response to military side I'm not the
right person to ask on that or be I am
seeing you know the next military
satellites and not being launched in the
UK so that begs a question on that but
there are different satellites at
different times
and then for me the most important thing
is around how do you get the UK to
understand the opportunity in space so
space is changing really really quickly
what Josh is doing just literally wasn't
wouldn't have been possible even five
years ago you can now as opposed to 10
years ago when a satellite was the size
of this room unbelievably expensive to
build up probably a billion dollars
payback period 30 years launch cost
absolutely astronomical so you know
something had to live for 30 years to
get your money back you can now build a
satellite for a hundred thousand dollars
and you can launch it for a hundred
thousand dollars the game has totally
changed and I think for me the most
interesting and I'm I'm not technical my
background is an investment banker
um what what's I think this is showing
and Josh is not technical either of his
doing a good job at learning it all is
there's so many applications for space
so whether you want to you know the next
if it does happen from the UK kernosat
which is you know to look at seaweed
developments everything from that
through another company involved in
called sap view which can look at is
building using infrared technology to
work out whether you should be
insulating it properly or not and
everything in between the applications
are amazing and I think it's getting the
UK public to understand that you don't
need to be astrophysics PhD you can be
as stupid as me particularly from a
technical perspective and go what's my
application I can look at biomass
development in the developing world and
work out where the next starvation issue
is going to be because crops aren't
developing and identify that six months
early the applications and what is
happening is is just so amazing and I
think
what what happened on that night of that
launch was both the excitement in new
key but also it was the lead story on
BBC there was there was live news and I
think everybody was it was a massive
feel good story massaging review but
more importantly I think everybody going
what does this mean for me what could I
do with this and I think a lot of people
would hopefully have gone home so I can
set up a business around this and I
think that that for me was yeah and kids
at school when I was taking school kids
down to to Cornwall yeah particularly
kids that are struggling at school they
go wow this is incredible you know I can
do everything from establish a
regulatory regime to you know make
tractors Drive in a straighter line and
spread fertilizer and so for me it's
it's it's a bit flippant to say it's
sort of a marketing exercise but it's
and then it's getting people to move to
Cornwall or move to Scotland or move to
Wales like Josh has done um and build
those businesses using very very bright
people from all parts of society
um you know very exciting jobs well-paid
jobs high growth growth an exciting
sector we're really good at is I mean
the government obviously has an
objective that we become a science
superpower investing more money in
science generally talking about
education and the inspiration that this
gives and we've done we've done an
inquiry into stem and you know inclusion
in that as well so if we don't develop
launch capabilities do you think that
has a major effect on our overall
ambition which we've obviously got this
new Department as well science
Technology Innovation do you think that
really says something about a lack of
ambition if we can't deliver orange
capability I think I think it really
comes back to two things I mean you know
can Josh keep building his business
outside the UK answer yes can the other
companies I'm involved in from a space
perspective do launch out of the UK
absolutely they can yeah and then you
know without wanting to be two two folks
like money you know there's this is
costing money you could decide tomorrow
we're actually not going to do this
anymore that frees up quite a lot of
money yesterday the UK sa who's doing
some fantastic work encouraging
companies in the UK now so 15 in for
lunar type projects
that could have been 100 million if you
don't do launch yeah I'm just pulling
numbers out of out of space
um but you know it's an opportunity cost
of money or you could go and build a
hospital and so that that I think that's
the way to look is this a good use of
money and I think the conclusion I've
reached right now is right now it's not
a good use of money because our
regulatory framework is not competitive
and again I'll stress again not I'm not
saying whether that's a right or wrong
view but it's not competitive with the
rest of the world so a commercial
company is going to go like and these
are not the US Australia Portugal
they're not sort of like you know
companies are just winging it
um you know it's not like Josh and I
going around we're going to go somewhere
that's a bit off the track and you know
we're taking yeah we're going to
grown-up countries with proper
regulatory Frameworks where it's cheaper
and easier
If I Could Turn Back to Mr Weston
briefly
um at the risk of asking you to
contradict your LED but um what would it
take for you to launch again in the UK
what would you personally need to see as
a CEO to launch again whether it's in
Cornwall or elsewhere in the UK
so we've we've publicly said already
that we would happily launch again from
the UK
um what we would need to see is progress
in the regulatory environment
are speeding up
um lower lower barriers to
um
you know overcoming some of those those
regulatory hurdles and I think at the
same time the the two things that also
matter is confidence in the launch
vehicle itself so you know if anything
apart from the failure it's suffered I
almost have more confidence now in a
virgin orbit launch because they'll fix
the problem and do it again so we always
say that we don't want to be anybody's
first time uh but really it's about
establishing a firm Cadence so as a
space Forge we're launching one more
Mission this year we're launching three
more next year one of those is already
signed up again for a launch from the US
and by 2026 we're looking at launching
12 platforms a year
at that sort of cadence
you know even even half of them
launching from the UK would provide a
significant anchor customer for that but
where we where we need that support is
on is in that regulatory environment
um and the pricing that UK launch can
achieve doesn't have to be as cheap as
America there are perks to not having to
send a team out of five to Florida for
three months but the closer we can get
to that
um the better and I think as well as as
much as we can we could debate
um whether or not we pursue launch I
mean we had we had that discussion as a
country after Black Arrow I I think it
really depends about what kind of global
partner and science superpower the UK
wants to be it's not it's not a question
I can answer but launch can make us a
partner to other countries to work with
um in a science and a space capacity
that without launch we simply can't
achieve thank you and just finally for
me uh you you mentioned that virgin
orbit will fix it next time are you
satisfied with the technical
explanations you've had as to the source
of the anomaly and the reason the launch
failed
I mean it's absolutely gutting that a
component's so small uh should cause
that failure
um but it's not without precedent either
it has already occurred
um in in other launches and I think in
many ways I'm grateful to have suffered
a failure like this so early on in our
journey and not with a much more capable
much larger platform with quite frankly
much more money riding on it than we had
um and and if anything I think
the the way that my team has responded
to that I mean they took a day to grieve
for the loss of that satellite it was a
lot of work and then they were already
heads down on the next mission
um so we're coming back from it better
um and and I think as well as we can uh
and we you know we still very much hold
our heads high for having tried to to
attempt it that's very good to hear we
all shared in your disappointment but we
look forward to seeing you launch again
thank you uh thank you just on that
point on the on the money
um were you insured uh or do your
investors have to um to pay
no we we took out insurance uh I believe
we were one of the only companies to do
so
um our satellite on that launch was
quite small uh so it wasn't it wasn't
too onerous it was maybe uh somewhere
between 10 and 20 000 pounds
um paid for across all of the different
insurances
um our broker is very good we've already
received about 80 of our money back
however
the insurance does only cover the cost
of the launch and the cost of the
materials it does not cover uh the
resourcing the engineering all the time
that we've lost from being involved just
to add on that there's a really really
important point it's it's multiples of
the the actual insured loss the piece of
Kit is almost irrelevant from a cost
perspective it's time it's just that
it's the case especially in the race
against other yeah competitors yes uh
Tracy Crouch and then Graham Stringer at
just during our inquiry into the UK
space sector we urge the government to
take steps to speed up the licensing
processing uh in order to get the the
launch sector up and running we haven't
had a response yet from government on on
these issues but are you seeing any
changes that your content with or do you
still think that things need to be sped
up and and
do you think that the the licensing
process is fit for purpose
I think the right questions are being
asked but the pace at which they're
being asked is is where really we're
losing
um what I would say again is that we're
going through the licensing process on
our four star one uh platform
um we started that I think in uh
September of last year again the
engineering and Technical teams of the
CAA are doing some fantastic engagement
and we have noticed uh how open and
responsive they are to our feedback
around certain aspects of the licensing
process
but I would
uh have to be honest and say that I
would not recommend
company go through their first license
in the UK
um it was uh quite painful at times it
was particularly onerous around company
checks so as a new entity we understand
the CAA need to be comfortable with we
are who we say we are
but the checks reached um a level of
detail that I haven't seen and I've gone
through security vetting uh and at times
we couldn't understand why that was not
a separate process to the license of the
satellite platform itself
um and so being able to progress those
as two separate tracks um would be
immensely helpful in helping other small
space companies literally get off the
ground would you say from your
interaction and engagement with the CAA
that they're learning lessons from the
process that you've had to go through
yeah absolutely I mean there has um
been a
there's been a real acknowledgment of
the
um
almost the level of unneeded oversight
on a company of our site I mean when we
started uh four star zero application
process I think we were around 20 25
people by the time that process had
concluded we were 46 people so we've
already massively increased and the
company as a presence has changed
significantly from the time that we we
submitted that original license you
think they're appropriately resource to
meet the demands of the UK launch
industry
particularly given obviously your
insight into other authorities and their
resources
so I can't I can't speak for launch but
from a satellite uh provider uh no
they're not they need more people the uh
the way in which my understanding of the
licensing process is so we can our
platform uh once we get to our second
generation four star two by around 2025
is a fairly standardized platform
um so that at that element of the
application should hopefully become
relatively streamlined for us however
the payload of each of those platforms
has the opportunity to be different
every time we would need to file a brand
new license for that payload each each
time there was a new one
um that could be uh particularly slow
especially if we're in the usual kind of
um 12 month offering around that mission
compared to some of these other um
regulatory uh kind of countries that
I've mentioned earlier
I think yeah star thing before you talk
about Staffing I think Josh touched on
it yeah what what's the inquiry that is
needed
um yeah can you lessen that and then you
work out how many people so the idea of
having more people doing
what Josh is I think taking words out of
your mouth there Josh too much work is
unhelpful so it's like reduce the
workload and then resource it
appropriately thank you that is really
helpful and and can I just seek
clarification uh on something please do
you consider that the delays in
licensing were the key reason that the
launch didn't take place in the summer
as planned or were there other uh
reasons but there were certainly other
but it was it was definitely a key
element of it
thank you
to Reflections coming briefly and then
Graham streamer very briefly the
print a it'll be fine and let's just
identify a risk um you know known risks
like you're throwing radioactive
material up in the satellite and we
might need to know about that or are
they going from a ground up perspective
where you have to tell them what it is
and they work out the plastic bits
aren't dangerous can you just give us an
idea of mentality
uh absolutely so the CAA from my
perspective they they have a very
sensible
um initial uh approach to risk so they
go for in what's known as an a-lap
approach as low as reasonably possible
so I'm very pleased to say space water
we don't deal with uh radioactive
material because that's far too
difficult
um
however
as low as reasonably possible it's
entirely subjective so it could be
subjective to the CAA it could be
subjective to the engineering or
technical person in receipt of your
license application uh it's different
between countries it's different between
even different Regulators so
understanding at what level you provide
at is is different depending on who's
reading your application I hope that
makes sense right okay so there's an
opportunity to provide upfront piracy to
speed the process thank you uh Grim
stream
they're just relying on
that question Mr Nicole I mean you've
given us pretty comprehensive
uh answers to things what I haven't got
clear in my own mind
is what we mean by appetite for risk
what uh what are the risks that are
being guarded against
yeah at the end of the day space is
difficult and it's risky I mean stuff
scuff can you know crash blow up land on
people land on shipment the night of the
launch there was a Spanish ship sailing
in in the the launch Zone it had to be
moved with 10 minutes to go um it's just
it's it's a question it's probably more
of a question to ca because you know I'm
not exact not involved intimately in the
detail of this
um that that just seems to be
a a lot there's a lot more worry that's
putting in sort of Layman's my terms in
the UK about this and there isn't other
countries too so to give you an example
when I chaired virgin orbit yeah when
you're not exec you worry about the
things that are most important you have
like you can worry about five or ten
things and then you let the exact team
get on with it regulatory process was
never on my list of things to worry
about it just it was just it never you
know it was just like okay here's a
report we don't need to talk about that
let's move on whereas for space Forge
um this was issue number one
[Music]
what I'm trying to get in my mind we you
often hear at the start of a project uh
people are being over uh cautious and
it's costing us a lot of money whether
it's building a nuclear reactor or
or whatever
um
costs a cut
several years later the thing blows up
there's an independent inquiry and the
costs children's so that's one side of
it on the other side of it
uh jumbo Jets large airplanes take off
all the time they don't land on ships in
the ocean they um rarely blow up on the
runway so what is different about this
that means that the CAA are taking uh a
severe look at other risk involved yeah
it is it's a 25 year old jumbo jet that
version that it flew across the Atlantic
yeah for many years but it is modified
and there is a rocket on it and it has
you know for one a bit of a word
ordinance on it and it's it's got
explosives on board so there is risk
without a doubt it's just a question of
you know
yeah you can't take everything to zero
what risk is you're willing to take it's
worked in the US which is not a helpful
comment for me to make the ca because
they have a legal obligation uh set out
by Parliament to run a process they
can't just rely on the US
um but it's it's a question yeah the
kind of questions Josh was getting I
mean Josh you talked to me a few times
about the fact that you're getting
questions about your CCTV system in a
small building in Cardiff yeah is that
the right level of detail to go to and I
know you can you're talking to Dan Hart
later I know that sort of he was
frustrated and probably being a bit mean
to Dan in terms of setting it up in
terms of the the area that was looked at
from a physical area that was looked at
from a risk perspective is selling more
than he was used to in the U.S so it's
probably something to ask Dan about who
was uh Dan Hart CEO of Virgin orbit uh
in terms of he can compare and contrast
in terms of what he's seeing in the US
and what he's been asked for in other
jurisdictions
yeah how can you be very clear that the
process should speed up
uh Josh is being clear that he should be
less expensive uh with the comparators
uh internationally and they should
change the basis of looking at risk is
it are there any other recommendations
you would make
I think it's sort of
I think there's a lack of appreciation
in terms of what matters to small
companies like space Forge that you know
I think for for a lot of big companies
or if you work in the public sector
turning up for work and you know getting
paid it's just accepted that it's going
to happen if you're a small company
you're going that's another day that I'm
closer to running out of money and also
to raise money you've got to be you know
showing a positive view of life and and
investors wants time and certain they
want they want certainty to budget and
certainty to time when things are going
to happen so I think it's an
appreciation and you know this is
again it's not a criticism CA or you can
say that the world's changed this is not
like dealing with Airbus who almost like
a government organization the the new
space economy is around small companies
that are startups that have limited
financial resources and limited people I
mean Josh has only got his his office is
he's built entire building including
manufacturing I'd say twice the size of
this room
um and I think the CAA is probably more
used to sort of going into a an Airbus
or something like that which has got you
know multiples of this room all over the
world as opposed to the reality around
what what does new space involve and all
the companies I'm working with are 20 30
employees
um with limited financial resources and
investors who understand the risks but
need to understand I mean Josh the
questions he gets from investors at the
Bulldog when's the next launch is it
definitely going to happen what are you
going to show when can we go and talk to
the new lots of investors about raising
more money for to hire more people and
create more jobs in the UK
I know a question it's asking Aaron's
question really you know slightly
different way
what are the implications if we don't
get this right uh for UK based companies
and for our International reputation in
the world of space
I mean I think I'd sort of tone that
round slightly and try and be positive
uh
space what's happening in the space
world as I said earlier is amazing it's
incredible what's happening and it's
literally going to change our lives and
our children where they're going to work
and all that kind of good stuff and what
it's going to do I saw Grant chefs
yesterday talking about Net Zero space
is a huge enabler on that it's
incredibly exciting the UK is one of the
leaders of that and it doesn't
necessarily need launch to make that
happen now is it a bit awkward is it a
bit difficult do I feel very sorry for
people in Cornwall and Cornwall Council
and all the people who've worked
unbelievably hard to make that launch
happen that's very it's very very
difficult
but the UK space industry can still
survive and thrive without domestic
launch personally I think it'd be great
if it could have launched but it's not
it's not a must-have it's a nice to have
but it's a nice it's got to be a nice to
have in an environment where where we're
competing with other spaceports around
the world thank you thank you Steve
Metcalf had a follow-up question uh yes
thank you you mentioned earlier about
um we might explore why the UK wants to
be in space in the first place I don't
think we've actually had that question
directly to you so I would be interested
in why you think we should be there
launch or in in the space industry in in
both actually I can more in launch
because actually I think we know why we
want to well I think yeah we should
definitely be in the space industry I
mean I think it's one of the things that
the UK excels at and yeah what Josh is
doing and there are lots of Josh's
around the country right now doing
similar so not quite as good as Josh
obviously but doing similar stuff uh and
it is properly amazing and going into
his facility and talking to his his team
there I mean Josh is assembled 45 people
I think you said Josh in Cardiff to work
on on a satellite project that's that's
amazing uh and he's doing it in a in an
old garage in Cardiff and these people
are out there uh and yeah it's a very
young team it's a very diverse team it's
incredibly exciting and that's happening
all over the UK
um and as I say the output from that
yeah what Josh is doing we haven't
really talked about what Josh is doing
making allies in space that are going to
be you know 50 more effective from and
electricity usage
um
requirements by you know making things
in space and bringing them back to Earth
so he's talking to British Telecom one
percent of the UK's electricity
consumption he can make a massive
difference there so that's just one
anecdotal example yes we should
definitely be doing space yes the UK is
really good at it but for me there are
three elements there's launch there's
building the kit and then there's the
applications do we have to do launch no
is launch very expensive is it very
risky yes
do we do satellites what we're doing
already we're actually really good at
that and there's some yeah that's
happening across the UK the really
interesting bit for me is the
applications and that's where I think
the UK needs to make sure that it's
moving with the rest of the world and
right now I think in a lot of places
it's ahead of a lot of the world maybe
not America maybe a couple of other
questions but we're we're a world leader
on this and I think you know for the UK
to thrive in the future it's really
really important but as I keep on saying
launch I think is a very nice to have
but not a must-have and in the current
construct it's not a must-have the other
two that you mentioned about uh
satellite application they're not
predicated on having the launch capacity
no I mean yeah if yeah again taking the
extreme on that if if we had to have
launched competency on the UK from the
UK Josh should give up now because right
it's not going to happen so do you think
that the UK I mean we've talked about
this for a little well quite a number of
years now and about establishing launch
capability
do you think we actually want to do this
I mean are we making it too difficult
for ourselves is it in that pile of
stuff that yeah okay it's a new area to
regulate and actually it's a bit tricky
and let's make it as difficult possible
for people like Josh so that they
actually go elsewhere and then we don't
have to deal with it I definitely don't
think it's deliberate
um I think people do want it and I think
the people I've met at the ca are very
proud being involved in it and want to
make it happen and yet anybody who's in
Cornwall Melissa's here but you know the
atmosphere there was amazing that just
the excitement of making this happen and
people being involved in it was
incredible
um but it's not working and either we
change that with the seismic shift or we
decide we're not going to do it we save
the money and we spend it on other
things which are you know unbelievably
exciting and final because where we are
now just ain't working
yes right
thank you Stephen uh can I thank Mr
Weston and Mr McCall uh I I'm Sorry Miss
Weston we didn't get the chance to ask
you about uh your technology in more
detail
um we're we're very excited about that
but the um uh the question that we're
looking into today is the uh is the
regulatory arrangements and you've been
both of you uh very helpful in giving us
the context for us to ask some further
questions uh later this morning so thank
you very much indeed uh and thank you in
particular for joining us from Melbourne
I'm going to invite the thank you next
witnesses to come to the table one
virtually
um and I will introduce them uh as they
take their seats
um so we have joining us from uh Los
Angeles Dan Hart who is the Chief
Executive Officer of Virgin orbit he
previously spent 30 years at Boeing
where he was most recently vice
president of government Satellite
Systems he's also worked on GPS uh wide
band global satcom and the x-37 space
plane uh thank you very much indeed for
uh joining us uh very uh the very latest
match or very early in the morning I
think it's about two in the in the
morning uh in La uh and it is your
birthday which is uh particularly uh
good of you to uh interrupt it and
joining us I'm pleased to say at the
table uh is Melissa Quinn who is the
chief executive of Spaceport Cornwall uh
and uh she is one of the they're saying
one of the first female Spaceport
leaders in the world and uh important uh
recognition that we should give in a
committee that wants to improve our
participation by women
um uh but this previously worked for
Arrow Hub called wall which supported
Aerospace and space Hub uh businesses
very grateful to you both for coming
ministers you were traveling up you
might have missed some of the praise
that was heaped on you and your team in
terms of the very hard work uh and
commitment you made to the launch which
must have clearly been a great
disappointment perhaps we consult with
you that's just um describe you know a
few few weeks on uh what's your
recollection uh of the of the launch was
and any Reflections to to kind of kick
off our our questioning today yeah well
thank you for having me um and lovely to
see everybody yeah it's been quite a
journey
um up to launch itself I've been part of
it since it started back in 2014 it's
Facebook Cornwall so it's been quite a
roller coaster ride
um up to launch which was just
absolutely incredible and such a huge
moment for my team Cornwall the country
and personally you know we put so much
energy into this and anybody that works
in the space industry launched
specifically knows that the sacrifices
that people make in it including our
families as well so a lot culminated in
that moment and obviously it not going
how we hoped it would
um was was really disappointing for
everybody
um you know because we have put all that
time and energy and passion and emotion
into it I think you saw that probably on
the night my my picture on the front
page of a lot of papers crying it was
not something I expected
um so yeah of course it was it was
disappointing and I you know shared some
time with with Dan and his team because
they're just as passionate about what
they do and they're absolutely edible
with what they do and bringing lunch to
the UK but since then it's definitely
been a lot of time to reflect
um and the first reflection was we got
to space you know the first time ever
from UK soil that was huge and
remembering that that we made that his
that history happened from Cornwall from
a you know small Regional Airport after
a pandemic you know all the things that
have happened was really inspirational I
think still I I should have bought them
today but I have thousands of letters
from school children all across the
country all across the world saying how
inspirational it was mostly not even
realizing that the satellites didn't get
to where they need to be they just
absolutely loved it so we're kind of
building you know the momentum back from
a lot of those positives and definitely
you know the step like today in looking
at getting that second launch that's
hugely important to us as a Spaceport
we're licensed we're ready we have that
license and that's something that we
want to use and we want to ensure that
the UK use it as well and that companies
like virgin orbit want to use so for us
it's about how how do we get to that
point so that we can be the Spaceport
that we you know we're just at the
beginning of this really and I I
wouldn't want to lose it before it
really gets started thank you very much
indeed well that's very clear perhaps I
can uh turn to Mr Hart uh We've
obviously got the uh what went wrong uh
with the the launch itself which was I
think a dislodged fuel filter
um perhaps I might ask you just to say
something about that update us as to
what the latest uh thinking of that is
but you may have heard from our previous
session that we've been advised not to
to get as it were too hung up on what's
called what tripped up the the launch
itself but to try to learn lessons from
some of the aspects of Licensing and
regulation that led to First delays
um and you know where we are at the
moment which is that we don't have a
future pipeline so could could you
reflect on on both those things the
immediate problem and what led up to the
launch
certainly
um well let's see you know getting to
the the the issue that we had uh and and
we'll get into you know a lot of things
went right as uh
um Melissa just mentioned that the issue
that we had was a a fuel filter
uh apparently became dislodged and
um affected the fuel pump of our second
stage this was after the first stage had
flown and we were we were going on the
order of 11 000 miles per hour when the
second stage ignited
um the fuel filter affecting the pump
affected the operation of the second
stage engine which actually operated for
for quite a while but eventually uh
because of heat buildup uh had a failure
and that caused
um the system to uh
turn off and and continue along the
trajectory which was planned in case of
an issue uh to be a safe trajectory and
and it eventually fell into the ocean
uh thank you and uh
have you concluded those investigations
or is is there some way to go before you
definitively you know close the the the
book on that we're well along the way we
have some experiments that we're doing
um we're doing a very formal
investigation as you'd expect
um with independent experts as well as
government uh oversight
um and so we're actually right now in
the middle of doing some experiments to
make sure that we can uh relate flight
Telemetry and data to ground test
results and and clinch it
um in the in parallel we are building
our uh or finishing the build of our our
next rocket which actually has that
filter designed out of it but we we want
to make sure that we have our finger on
exactly the issue and we can share that
okay thank you
and and your other question as far as
what the build up
um you know I I would say number one is
this was
um an enormous undertaking
um I mean we're a we're a fairly small
Aerospace company as aerospace companies
go
um it was an honor frankly to be in the
position to attempt this first launch
um and I I think uh Melissa and her team
at Spaceport Cornwall Ian uh Annette at
uksa and and Tim Johnson and the team at
CAA as well as the RAF
um uh um and air Vice Marshall goddess
and and uh or Godfrey and others uh who
supported us
um it was a hugely complex undertaking
um
the logistics aspect of Performing the
mission was uh quite a bit of
undertaking and then the safety aspects
of planning and carefully planning and
going through the regulatory
um in terms of the regulatory
environment
you know the first surprise that we
probably got was and and Mr Western sort
of alluded to this the aylarp process
um we had anticipated that the FAA
process would be
sort of start off as the founding
portion and we could then use that
documentation and Analysis and but we
found
um relatively early on was that we would
need to reformulate that in a unique UK
regulatory
set of documentation analyzes
um so that that was that was somewhat
unexpected and would be helpful if if
the two were more compatible uh would be
you know number one that I would point
out
um number two is
you know what we found was a I mean the
CIA was involved but there were many
organizations that had a interest or a
statutory requirement to have an
interest in the in the launch whether it
was Maritime or environmental or health
and safety or or others they're nuclear
and and and lots of organizations and
and what we found was we needed to
rehash information many times and
sometimes the asks would change in terms
of the level of depth or the kinds of
information that we needed so there
wasn't a what I would call a central
Clearing House
where you know you're putting your
information in and then the system is is
satisfied
um and things changed along the way
um on our expectations changed
um we we all plotted forward
um but that was a that was difficult I
mean we were all taking a fair amount of
risk of whether we were actually going
to be able to do this or whether the the
the rules would change in such a way
that that we wouldn't be able to uh
perhaps the largest example of that was
um you know it was alluded to I think
earlier that the hazard area
in the that was determined that needed
to be established at the airport
um was a pretty late breaking
development
um in the fall I think of last year
where it was determined that the hazard
area that we had proposed was was not
adequate and we needed a larger one that
caused quite a burden on the airport
to to accommodate it
um enclosing roads and businesses and so
forth
um and then the last part that I'll
mention in at this piece is um
perhaps is is the um you know there was
airspace to negotiate
um there were things that that there was
range that needed to be evaluated and
and there's a perhaps a rethinking of
what a company is capable of doing we've
mustered through it and eventually we
usually asked for help and and often
eventually we got it and I'm grateful
for that but we can probably think
forward if uh the next time and think
about okay you know if virgin orbit asks
a ship to leave an area it's probably
not going to be as effective as if the
Coast Guard does
uh and maybe we can set up those you
know those those interfaces uh right
from the get-go
um you know again I would say it was a
huge undertaking
um my team
had their heart and soul in US
um we were tremendously disappointed
that we didn't get to orbit
um and most of all I I really apologize
to the spacecraft that we didn't we
didn't deliver
thank you very much uh indeed for that
just to to kind of follow up on the the
approach to regulation I mean was it the
case that for example that the aircraft
the 747 needed to be licensed by the the
CAA or were they was this is a pretty
pretty familiar aircraft
um was the FAA approval sufficient for
this or did it need to be specifically
licensed
it had to be sufficiently licensed uh I
mean specifically licensed um and there
was there was interchange on both sides
um we have an experimental certificate
because it it does have a special pylon
a rocket holder under the wing
and and so it's it's the the aircraft is
under an experimental license and so
um there was work to do there I would
say that probably wasn't the hardest
part of it although uh it was a risk
that you know of working through the
agencies and making sure everything
would work out um and we got there would
you have expected that to have been a
kind of a mutual recognition of the
standards of a of a regular regulator of
the you know the kind of the depth and
experience of the FAA would you expected
more of a uh a kind of passport system
to apply that if you improved in that
jurisdiction it could apply here
that was our expectation
um you know that we would need to
perhaps that we would take that as the
foundation and then we did expect that
we would need to have lots of technical
interchange I mean when we work with the
FAA you know we spend hours and hours
discussing and talking with the
engineers and frankly good questions
come up and and to the CIA people the
engineers and the team lots of good
questions did come up lots of good
interchange
um and when the engineers get together I
think answers actually happen quickly I
I think there may be
methodologies uh associated with that
that might improve things to to have
more of that interchange so that when
the documentation comes comes out it's
it's Crystal Clear to everybody what
everything is that's one way to be more
efficient thank you just before I change
my colleague starting with uh Aaron Bell
of course there were there were multiple
delays to the
to the intended launch date and at one
point on the 9th of December 2022
virgin Orbitz put out a statement that
the launch itself had to be put off
because the licenses were outstanding
both for the launch itself and for the
satellites within the payload
um do you do you recall that the
decision to postpone these launchers
being connected with the those lack of
regulatory licenses having been issued
well I I remember the delay the reason
also included needing to assure the
health of the rocket and we had an issue
we were working also and so what we
found ourselves with
was we were working at a technical issue
and working really hard to get it in
before the end of December
when we looked at our our the windows
that were allotted to us at that time I
believe there were two days that were
approved for launch Windows in December
um and we didn't have our license yet
um and so when you stacked all that
together
uh it it was not practical that we could
you know pull a rabbit out of the hat
and and and and get all of our work done
and all of our certifications and have a
window available to us when we needed it
so you know I would not put that all on
licensing although licensing played a
part so on that so you you were clear in
your statement that it was some
technical work that was required uh and
the licensing I was surprised and I
think um a committee was surprised that
when you made that statement there was a
very Swift and robust response from the
ca the regulator saying that the delay
in no way relates to uh to the timing of
a license being issued by the CAA what
you've just told the committee is that
it was two things it was a technical
thing and it was a license issue
that you would have a public
you know kind of Tit for Tat from from a
regulator like that
I I mean I I there's some questions I I
think you I would defer to the CAA there
but I I mean I there was a lot of I
think there was a lot of focus and
desire to clarify I would just say we
are used to operating in an environment
where we have several days and we have
backup days to Launch
and so you know we're used to taking our
our time and you know we have to make
sure everything is right and we always
do before we go forward
um and so therefore you know looking
forward and having a couple of days
approved
and and maybe one or two more that might
get approved but we don't know that they
will was not a comfortable place for us
to be and honestly that's one aspect
that we would need to re-look at going
forward thank you very much Lee I'm
going to turn to my colleagues uh Aaron
Bell
um and then Stephen Metcalfe and Rebecca
Long Bailey thank you chair if I could
turn back to you Miss Quinn um about the
impact on Spaceport Corner we saw the
impact they had on you and and you
described it but the annual staff what
about the wider area and and you know
people of new key and so on is it has it
affected the area that the launch failed
um I would say that if anything it's had
a more positive impact especially from
as I said earlier the the kind of
inspiration side of things we've been
out in the community a lot talking about
you know picking yourself up going again
this stuff happens in life and and that
strong messaging especially for young
people
um has been really important and
actually has has brought a lot of more
interest to to what we're doing
um there has been questions obviously
with with the major Council investment
into this
um about you know what is the future of
this what does it mean
um was it good value for money for
Cornwall
um and I would say 100 if anything from
that inspiration side but also the fact
that we were on
um we're in global newspapers all around
the world we've had we've been inundated
with space companies wanting to come and
locate in Cornwall because of the launch
um so from from our perspective I've
just seen anything the positives of
course yes local media are have the
headlines of it's failed what a waste of
money you know and they're not seeing
the wider picture of what we've achieved
over the last you know eight to nine
years leading up to the launch and then
since the launch we're about to open a
brand new building for satellite
manufacturing and satellite data
companies that's full and we haven't
even opened it yet because of the
interest on the back of the launch with
Virgin so I think looking at it Beyond
just the fact that yes the satellites
unfortunately didn't get to orbit but
what it created was this catalystic
effect
um and interest from media
school children and businesses thank you
Amy you're obviously from what you've
just said you're engaged with the local
community speaking to schools and so on
and so forth
do do you think the people in the area
understand the benefits it can bring
together as well as the obviously the
excitement but the commercial benefits
and the benefits for the economy of the
area as a whole
lot of work over the last few years on
community engagements it's been
fundamental because
I was over in America last week at the
global space Port Alliance so all the
spaceports in the world get together
once a year and I was asked to speak and
tell our story and one thing I said that
I think all the spaceports anywhere have
to do is properly engage with their
Community because the community and
local politicians local media have the
ability to to shut these projects down
and you can see cases of those all
around the world what has been
successful for us is that engagement
with the community going out and
understanding what their concerns are
but also where the opportunities are so
when it came to launch on the night we
were allowed 2 500 people on site
Eventbrite said we could have at least
had about the interest that they had in
one day ten thousand people from the
local area we were again inundated with
local communities wanting to be part of
it local businesses that have nothing to
do with space you know you know being
part of it and benefiting from it so I
think that I
the general consensus across the board I
would say in the community is yeah this
was really exciting when are you going
again how can we get involved
I guess that's very good to hear and if
I I know colleagues want to ask about
the future activities from Spaceball
corner so I won't tread on their tattoos
but can I ask what
um joint Lessons Learned activities
you've carried out together with Virgin
orbit I'll come to you in a minute Mr
Hart same question but also with the UK
space agency and the civil aviation
Authority what what joint lessons
learning activities have you had since
uh since the failed launch
once
I was with us and our Ops Team at the
airport which was really useful
um more unofficially you know what's
what do you think how should we move
forward with this
um we I mean Dan's team only just left
properly a couple weeks ago so we had
them still on site for a long period of
time so again working with them more
more unofficially than than anything
official and then this afternoon we're
sitting down with UK space agency and
and the government to discuss a more
formal Lessons Learned and I imagine
that will continue uh going forward but
we have yet to have a wide joined up
Lessons Learned with Virgin orbit with
CAA with UK space agency and with
ourselves and I would definitely
appreciate having something like that in
the near future thank you thank you Mr
Hart as well obviously you've had to do
the technical investigation yourselves
but what joint working have you done on
Lessons Learned and what lessons have
have you learned um so far
well we as as
um as Melissa just mentioned there's a
meeting this afternoon that I think is
the start of Lessons Learned um so there
really has not been a lot of interaction
um yet I mean I think uh as as Patrick
McCall said before there's a little bit
there's a bit of a seismic shift
that that we ought to think about on how
you know what is the core what is being
protected and and what is the most
efficient way uh to get there and then
what are the risk levels
um and so I'm I'm anxious to get into
some of that discussion and and I think
that could be very fruitful
thank you and and the specific source of
failure the the fuel filter I mean
there's a long tradition the tradition's
probably not the right word but a long
history in in the space industry that is
often the little things that people
hadn't thought of what what extra
measures will you take in future to
ensure that all of these the little
components are you know fit for purpose
at launch
yeah I mean there is a very very
involved process in place already on
many many hundreds and thousands of
components
um
we we're looking at filters as well as
any kind of installation you know uh
practices that uh that may need to be
changed again we we we're not sure if
it's an installation aspect or if
there's something associated with a
fluid dynamics uh situation we're doing
experiments right now so it's a little
bit early yet for me to put a pin on all
of it but we will look very broadly
at the the causes the contributors and
then we'll attack every single one
sounds like rocket science yes
um just on finally on on that point as
well is
the the checks that you did do before
the launch should they have picked up
this this failing or is it a case that
that need to be further checks you're
not able to say it it's it it's not
um it they would not have picked up uh
and there were significant checks there
are some things on the ground that you
don't quite replicate in your ground uh
from flight you know the g-forces some
of the vibration effects aerodynamics
you so you do tests and we did test this
area for leaks and for lots of things
um the the robustness of the design and
installation just need to be there and
that's what we're going to make sure of
thank you very much Mr hope thank you
very much indeed Stephen Metcalf then
Rebecca Long Bailey uh thank you just a
quick question and for absolute Clarity
um will you be pursuing another launch
from Cornwall and if so when do you
think that will be
yes uh we we have had some discussions
um
um it's unclear at this point it it you
know a launch starts with the payload
and the satellite
um and so there are options there
um as as Mr McCall mentioned there are
government satellites that are
candidates there are commercial
satellites that are candidates they're
also are are some ideas about
um university satellites it's for
education so there's a lot of there's a
lot can be done there but it starts
there
um the regulatory framework really does
need to be looked at and and hopefully
we can work together to improve
the process
um and and I'd say you know those are
the two the two keys uh pieces and and
then we would um
my team looks at me and says um when are
we going to finish this
okay in other words let's get to orbit
great
um but in terms of time scales for that
um all those things I recognize you need
a payload and you need to get licenses
in place but when do you think the next
attempt will be
I mean we could do it before the end of
the year
um I don't have confidence that the
other pieces will be ready by then
um and so I I think it's a it's a great
question
um but it really has to get
to to a a payload and B you know how
long does it take to really look at the
regulatory side and plan another mission
okay so an aspiration not a plan
perfect yes sir thank you very much
thank you thanks Dan and happy birthday
um
mentioned that the regulatory framework
needs to be locked out very briefly can
you let us know what the advantages and
the disadvantages of Virgin orbit
launching from the UK are compared to
its other launch options
well I think um you know
the the advantages really for us have to
do with
um engagement and participation in a
growing
UK space sector
um and and that sector really spans
commercial civil and National Security
um and so the the advantages for us is
is to be a a partner and a and a
um a trusted uh provider of space launch
the the technology that we've developed
is very unique in that a um we can take
a slab of cement
at an airport and the next thing you
know a week later there's a Spaceport
there
um and and I I with a lot of help from
Spaceport Cornwall uh mind you but but
that is very unique the other aspect is
you know we can fly out and and put the
rocket where it wants to be
um before it ignites and and obviously
there's a lot of neighbors and a lot of
airspace around the UK and so having
that flexibility we could fly north and
do Northern Northerly trajectories we
could fly further out and do various
trajectories from the south that's quite
a bit different than if you're sitting
on the ground at one launch pad and the
the last part is you know we got off on
a blustery Rainy Night in Cornwall which
which there are many
um
um there happened to be one here in
California tonight too
um but but
um we a ground launch rocket would not
have launched
that day and so I'm very proud of the
team I'm very proud of the technology we
developed and our Pilots because for
being able to navigate that and and on
the first opportunity to get off
um in a new Spaceport a new place so you
know for us it's it's being a part of
the community and uh part of the the
industry and and the economy and the
National Security requirements
um
and I I think uh we were uniquely
capable of doing it I should just point
out that the uh the Member of Parliament
for Newquay was in the committee room
earlier and he would hotly deny that
there are many blustery nights I think
they're exceedingly rare uh but Rebecca
on the issue of the regulatory framework
very briefly what do you think needs to
be looked at what changes would you like
to see the UK government make
um well so let me start with with the
the I would say the symptom and then the
question is you know what drives it the
we found ourselves in a position where
we were you know the the hazard area as
I mentioned the airport was very high
and impactful to to the airport and to
the Spaceport Cornwall and it costs a
lot of money there and it reduced our
flexibility the other thing is the the
amount of airspace that was determined
to be Hazard areas was much more than we
were used to you know when we fly past
San Diego and we fly past
um uh Mexico
um the the hazard areas are more tuned
towards where there are events like a
staging event on a rocket or something
like that
um and so why is that I think
um it would be useful to to really look
at what are the requirements um the
hazard area at the airport
um I'm not a
um a safety animal Us by trade but I
know it was developed assuming that a
hundred percent of the fuel and oxygen
could instantly combine and ignite and
that's a that's a enormously
conservative assumption usually what
I've seen is less than 20 percent is
assumed in Hazard analyzes on uh on on
ranges so I I think some of those
um would be important the other
important things are just roles and
responsibilities in having a central
clearing house where you know the the
rate there's a central regulatory
framework so we don't have to negotiate
with individual agencies
um I mean it was an enormous amount of
work uh to to to get everybody together
thanks Dan and Melissa um is work
underway at the moment to secure further
launch partners
yes um obviously our anchor tenant being
virgin orbit but we've always been very
clear that we want to be a multi-user
Spaceport
um the beauty of of our Spaceport is
where we're an active civilian airport
at the same time so we're about
integrating into the activities at the
airport which means that we're not just
about launch on the site which makes the
whole business model a bit more
sustainable in the sense that it's not
all legs in one basket so for us it's
about the quality over the quantity of
launches at Spaceport Cornwall to make
to make the business model work that's
why attracting other businesses whether
they're space or Aerospace to the site
off the back of the launch is really
important because when Virgin are not
here we want to be using the facilities
and making sure that we're
um you know make making good on all the
investment that's gone into the site and
so we have announced a partnership with
another launch operator called CR space
with Dream Chaser and they take off
vertically likely in the states and
they'll land they need a landing a long
Runway um and so we're working on a
concept of operations with them we have
space Engine Systems a Canadian launch
company that's just relocated over from
Canada that's just set up about a month
ago and we have a couple of other launch
operators but that being said with
horizontal launch there's not a lot of
players in the game and so the fact that
we're you know our anchor tenant being
virgin orbit who is the the premier of
and the the main launch operator
globally for horizontal launch is a huge
cue for the for the UK
um as I said I was just over um at Cape
Canaveral and U.S space force we're
talking to us or talking to the whole
conference about using Allied spaceports
around the world to for National
Security the only non-us Spaceport they
put up on their map was baseball
Cornwall the the importance of
maintaining this capability for the UK
and I know what Patrick I understand
what Patrick was getting at earlier
saying launch we don't need it I think
as the way the world is going if we
don't have our own access to space from
the UK when we were building these
incredible satellites for National
Security but yet we might not be able to
replace them I think that leaves us out
in the cold and I guess for me I know
the regulations have been difficult
believe me from a Spaceport perspective
we understand but they have been
difficult for everybody and I think this
is our chance now to get it right
because but saying that we don't need a
launch capability I think would be the
wrong decision
um not just from you know creating
Market opportunity for the US making
sure that these satellites can launch
from home soil but also from a national
security perspective
um so for me you know that is that is
fundamental that we yes of course
um make sure that we're we're supporting
companies like virgin orbit to launch
but also future companies as well and by
creating that one you know Spaceport
that we have licensed already here now
and making sure that we're backing it
and it is a National Asset it's not just
Cornwall Council and virgin orbit it's a
National Asset that I hope the UK want
to use for all those different reasons I
just mentioned thank you and very
briefly I understand that you might not
be able to disclose too much information
on this point because it might be
commercially sensitive but you mentioned
that virgin orbit is your anchor tenant
are there any potential restrictions
that would restrict you from
um securing future arrangements with
future operators
um no the decision by Commonwealth
Council to invest in the Spaceport back
in 2019
um supported a Pathfinder launch with
Virgin orbit
um and that's why you saw the investment
going into the site and and into virgin
orbit was we wanted to create that
capability we don't have it here so for
us that that initial pot of funding was
was really important and crucial that we
you know made again proved that
capability
um and then I think sorry was the
question remind me of the question is
there anything that would restrict you
from going forward future Partners no as
long as for us again that they we know
when they're coming back to launch that
they have access to the facilities when
they need them
um that of course will will have a
priority over the the next few years
definitely
um but there's nothing in contractually
saying that we can't work with other
people okay thank you thank you just I
mean would any payments be triggered to
Virgin if you did
um host another launch from another
company our commercial agreements for
the first launch only and we'll be
negotiating with the with the future
agreement
agreements so so in the case of Virgin
so the the anchor tenancy was for that
launch for that launch yes and that's
that's expired now at the end of
February yeah it expired then so at the
end of February
um then so there's there is no anchor
tenant at the moment it's a it's a kind
of
uh for excuse the expression it's a
virgin sight
uh no we have other people coming in now
to use the facilities they can but they
said but it's back entirely in your
control you've got no contractual
commitments but put another way no
contractual uh engagements um from any
other launch company nothing contractual
just mou
Catherine Fletcher wanted to come in
with supplement thank you very much
very much hand at the end of that
question so uh do you want to just come
back before I go off yeah
yes if I could I I thought Melissa
brought up a very important point and I
just want to emphasize it um you know uh
it has to do with the importance of
space launch in the future
um you know space assets
have become and will be more of the
fundamental infrastructure that are
supporting
um the UK's economy
understanding of the environment and
National Security
um
you know we're just if you play it back
20 years and and how space
was used and you play it to now you see
tremendous changes I mean we we know
what's going on in the Ukraine because
of space assets we look at it in the
evening news every every day we look at
imagery we weren't doing that 20 years
ago
um you know we communicate with space
um we're going to manufacture in space
as as Josh Western mentioned before
um so it really is a part of and will be
more and more a part of the
infrastructure supporting us and that is
why it's really an important piece
um and if you play it forward 10 years
when if something blinks out or there's
a disaster or a situation that requires
a space asset
um it will become more and more
important to get something in the right
place at the right time really and I I
and I think that is you know that is the
point and I I just wanted to agree with
with Melissa I couldn't agree with her
more that's beautifully put and probably
back to where I'm coming from is let's
say I 100 agree with you although I'll
hold my right to reserve my mic to
change my mind but let's if that's the
case let's get this right so you
mentioned the idea of maybe having a
central regulatory framework and
preventing dealing with multiple
agencies at the risk of testing your
memory could you give us a flavor of who
they are you've got the CIA you've got
the FAA I presume you've got local
Council planning which is have you got
the environment agency could you just
give us an idea of what the UK local and
national government regulatory framework
looks like as a user of it
I I can somewhat and I could get you a
better list um and you rattled off some
of them there but yeah yes the CAA on
the space side the CAA on the aircraft
side
um the maritime Community I think there
are a couple of different communities
there there's the environmental
Community
um there's health and safety both at the
federal and as well as the local level
um and I and and then there's airspace
um and there's International airspace
um and so you know there's a enormous I
would say
well over a dozen maybe a couple of
dozen different communities that we had
to brief and get get comfortable
eventually
um you know the statutory review
required nuclear and other communities I
tell you what it would be wonderful to
get the long best on the record and I'm
conscious of time but if you could write
to the committee I'd be very grateful
thank you chair thank you very much and
just so one final question uh for me uh
if I may uh you're a global uh company
um you've got
um agreements Arrangements in place not
just with the UK but with Japan with
Poland with Brazil with Australia with
Luxembourg obviously the us we've heard
from our evidence today how attractive
it is for countries to host launch
partly to help their own space and
satellite industry but partly to to
generate some public excitement around
it you're pretty Footloose uh you know
are you not going to increasingly expect
to go to places in which the local
jurisdiction
got National governments and local
governments make it worth your while in
other words pay your costs
yes we're and we're a business
um and so we only survive uh through
through our our economic value that we
can bring to our shareholders so so yes
uh thank you very much indeed uh both of
you for uh your evidence today that is
uh extremely helpful to have we're now
going to ask the the UK Regulators to
come and join us at the table uh so as
we do that I will introduce them and we
have
foreign Hillier who is the chair of the
Civilized civil aviation Authority uh
took over the chair in August 2020
Stevens had a very illustrious career in
the Royal Air Force uh before that
becoming chief of the air staff he's got
extensive military flying experiences
you would expect and we're very grateful
to him for coming today and we would
like to welcome back Tim Johnson who is
the policy director for the CAA helped
us with the inquiry to which this is a a
follow-on response and we also have Ian
Annet who is from the UK space agency
joined the agency in 2020 as Deputy CEO
for program delivery and he's
responsible for the delivery of all
national space programs across the
agency including the space flight
program uh thank you very much indeed
you've been kind enough to sit through
the the evidence that we've had from
other Witnesses and so the questions
that we have won't surprise you because
they are in effect the questions that
they have put put to us and I guess it
it amounts to to this
we've recognized in this country through
the government and other agencies an
opportunity that we want to take to have
have satellite launch space launch in
this country we've got a very strong
satellite industry we we wanted to have
a first mover advantage in this at least
in in Europe
and we had this through the uh the
Cornwall space launch but what we heard
especially in the first panel is that
we've thrown that away and that now
commercial investors will positively not
invest all the assessment is that are
unlikely to invest in the UK and the
whole thing needs to be rebooted with
public sector customers to re-establish
our reputation because of the the
regulatory approach that's been taken so
Stephen what's your response to that
thank you very much indeed and thank you
for this opportunity and if I could just
start to answer that question by saying
from a civilization Authority
perspective
um we see we've got two roles we are the
regulator we've also see we have a role
to play in enabling uh successful
Aerospace Enterprise suppose Aviation
and in in space clearly we have a
statutory Duty in relation to regulation
but in terms of enablement then we are
very active in uh trying to play our
part in enabling a thriving Aerospace
and in this case space environment so we
play in both of those those roles
in terms of what we've heard already
today in the situation that we are in
um then uh clearly there are lots of you
know positive comments there and there's
lots of empties as well on um lessons
identified and we are absolutely a
learning organization and we want to
play our part to the full and that's a
really participating in that process at
the moment we have a key role to play
and has already been covered work to do
uh in the next couple of days as we
start to bring all of that together so
there's lots of great points have come
out there
but what I need to come back to is
um what is that core role that the CAA
was performing is to enact the
legislation uh which was given to us and
that our primary duty is to ensure that
the space activity in the UK is
conducted safely it's the it's conducted
within the alarp principle which I have
to say is as low as reasonably
practicable one of the earlier Witnesses
said possible there's a really
significant difference between possible
and practical but it's practicable and
it will relies on things like safety
cases Etc so that is the foundation of
the uh the work that we have been doing
the final thing I'll just say is that um
to be honest I don't think there's been
enough balance so far on technical
readiness
and that was the thing which was very
much focus of the CAA certainly in the
second period of last last year
the previous virgin orbital launch was
on the 2nd of July 22.
in Mojave Desert
the average for Virgin orbital launches
is about six months between launches so
it was always going to take a period of
time for them to reconstitute certainly
in another country in a new operation
and then
actually deliver the mission
and in terms of how the sequencing
worked the CAA licensed from our
perspective we're confident that we
license in advance of technical
readiness
and so you mentioned chair that exchange
of Correspondence last year
it is very unusual for the CAA to go
public and make a regulatory statement
to the stock exchange and say it's not
the licensing
that's not down to us it's a very
unusual step and we would not take that
sort of Step lightly
so as far as we're concerned we licensed
in December and the launch happened in
in January and there were technical
issues which were running through there
perhaps I just paused their uh chair
well indeed you say there were some
positive things set and your your
engineers were singled out for
particular praise uh in that and that
that certainly needs to be acknowledged
but net net the I mean the evidence that
we've heard
not just from space Forge but from
Virgin orbit is the most devastating
evidence I've heard on a commercial
regulatory uh context since I've been
chairing this committee something that
was a strategic priority for this
country to be ahead of the world we've
heard evidence from investors and
operators to say that their experience
of Regulation here has put us behind the
rest of the world so I don't think it
can be what one could hide behind the
the Excellence of the engineers that you
employ there is clearly a big problem
with the the approach to regulation in
the eyes of those who deal with
jurisdictions right across the world and
are going to go to them in the future
rather than the the UK and are warning
publicly others not to come to the UK
that is as the chair of the the
regulator not something that you can be
comfortable with I would submit
in terms of
um where people have criticized us for
our engagement and absolutely
um then uh we under we recognize what
they say but I'd look at it from the
perspective of
um the civil aviation Authority took on
this role in July of 2021. I went ran
through from the CAA board perspective
and in that period we've had 18 board
meetings from then until now at a dozen
of those board meetings space and our
progress with space was a substantive
matter for discussion and debate
including an extraordinary board meeting
too in advance of the the Virgin orbital
launch I have to say that is greater
than the application that we've applied
to virtually any other area of our
business in terms of Engagement I know
that and Tim Johnson will cover this uh
shortly uh six separate visits to Virgin
orbital in the Mojave Desert and
countless other engagements that we have
done across the process in terms of
wider sector
um yes there was the licensing
associated with Virgin orbital but I'm
not getting as much publicity as it
should frankly is that the CAA has
issued so far in the last 18 months or
so 285 space licenses
12 of them were related to the Virgin
orbital license but the other
273 of them were more widely on the very
day that disappointingly and the ca
absolutely shares the disappointment
that this launch was not a success so we
feel we have a key role to play here we
feel this as well but on that day 40
other CAA licensed satellites went into
orbit
so in terms of the focus that we give
this uh absolutely and I I know that the
committee looked at its last meeting at
the size of our space team 35 at the
time it's nearly 50 now and it's growing
all the time and the reason is is
growing is because we are investing the
resources from a CAA perspective to
ensure that we have the match the
capacity needed as the industry starts
to continues to develop in the in the UK
um and if I look at it from a personal
perspective
um I have engaged at least twice with
every constituency MP in potential space
ports around the the UK I have written
to them uh as as well
um I have engaged with the sector uh
myself and I clearly I know a lot of the
players from my previous rules as well
and I'd say I would say that
proportionately this has been a huge
investment from the CAA you know we've
got it uh here and I feel that we're
playing our part uh in that I mean you
take us back to the inquiry that the
committee conducted and it was before
the uh it was before the launch and we
took a lot of evidence including from Mr
Johnson and what we heard we we take our
evidence from from Witnesses either
appearing in person or many more who
write to us and the conclusions that we
came to which would to be to be worried
about whether the CAA was the right body
to be entrusted with his regulation
previously space has been under the UK
space agency we heard from others
including some of the Scottish
spaceports that they were concerned
about delays and uncertainty in in
regulation we heard worries about the
capacity the numerical capacity of the
of the team we heard worries about the
the duplication or the the creation of
different standards we we reported all
that in terms of recommendations
they weren't taken up either by the cea
or the the government uh
and then what we've had in the context
of the Fatal launch in Cornwall which I
think it's clear is not about the the
technical faults but it has given the
opportunity to look back and I can't see
that any one of those recommendations
was offbeam and yet Mr Johnson you
rebutted them at the time when when we
were when we were forming them you said
that you had the right number of people
that you were the right organization
that you were operating in an agile way
do you reflect back that actually that
was the the wrong state to give the
committee
and as Steven has outlined we um
increased uh the size of the team during
the course of the year to reflect uh the
workload so we we did sort of pay what
you say and reflected on it
um throughout the year we did uh make
substantive progress but we also
um learned lessons
um along the way so I can think of a
number of areas where working with some
of the operators we adjusted our um
engagement plan we up to the you know
the frequency of our rates we were
talking to virgins baseball Cornwall in
a number of different guises you know at
least two to three times a week we
amended for example our approach to the
environmental assessments
um having had some initial feedback from
Spec's book Cornwall and virgin on the
approach there
um as Stephen said we're a learning
organization
um there's a Lessons Learned process
across all the parties going on at the
moment we've already identified a number
of aspects of our something called our
Regulators rules which deal with some of
the points I think that space forward
spaceforge made at the outset some of
the other changes that we might want to
think about relate to legislation
whether that be sort of set out in the
secondary or primary legislation when it
comes to some of the the detail of the
the approaches and Mr Stephen you've had
a brilliant career in the RAF you've
been used to dealing with the the Armed
Forces particularly Air Forces of other
countries militaries military
cooperation is something that I'm sure
you practiced every day during the the
the height of your military career why
is it the case as we've heard repeatedly
today that the standards and the
licensing of a respected an organization
as the Federal Aviation Authority the
FAA is not passported and respected here
that you taking an approach to the cea
to revisit it all and and start from a
blank sheet of paper why surely you
could bring from your previous career
the recognition of the good work that's
done by trusted allies
well I mean just referring to that
previous uh career then uh it is the
case that uh sometimes on occasion we do
Mutual recognition as we would uh we'd
call it and other times we don't the UK
has its own specific requirements so
that exists in uh in defense as much as
it does in civil Aerospace in terms of
our relationship with the FAA it's an
excellent relationship
um at all levels and uh as you may be
aware we even have an FAA secondian or a
Space Team to make sure that we transfer
as much of those uh lessons as possible
and we have enormous respect for what uh
the U.S system has achieved over six
plus Decades of space launch capability
why don't we just passport it in
um well to be honest that's not what the
legislation says the legislation says
that the UK has its approach and that
includes things which are uh like the
alarp principle and the building of
safety cases and the whole emphasis in
the UK system is it's not for us the
regulator to tell the entity how to be
safe it is for them to build the safety
case and say Here's why they think it is
safe and then we describe the regulatory
framework and we do the Assurance within
that it's a different approach to uh
regulation now whether that's right or
whether that's uh that's wrong but our
duty as a civil aviation Authority is to
enact the legislation which requires us
to do these things clearly we've heard
that things have gone wrong in the sense
that we've we've fallen behind other
countries and we've heard evidence that
Australia and Portugal for example are
taking an approach that is more
accommodating of of work that's been
done by the FAA in particular so are you
saying that you're prevented by the
legislation from doing that and is it
right that this committee shouldn't take
a recommendation from you that that the
the legislation needs to change because
you're being hemmed in by it I don't
think the uh the regular the statutes
need to change
we are working as I say very closely
with the FAA and um I I do believe there
are areas where we can do Mutual
recognition
um at a particular level consistent with
the legislation that we have currently
in the the UK
um but
um you know we have to respect things
like the geography and the the caa's
primary role is to ensure the safety of
this activity and that's the safety of
the general public on the ground who
might be affected by this launch
activity and there is the obvious
difference between launching from the
Mojave Desert and going out over the
Pacific over a single nation's airspace
or launching from Australia again single
Nations airspace and sparsely populated
area there's a world of difference
between that and somewhere like new key
and Cornwall where there is clearly a
lot of population around uh I mean we
previously heard from Spaceport Cornwall
two and a half thousand people there
watching this launch activity actually
happening that doesn't happen in the
Mojave Desert and then going out into an
international airspace and having to
negotiate
um with a whole range of other nations
for this launch activity so we have very
specific things from a UK perspective
and there is a a UK approach which is we
are responsible for the safety
um philosophy if you like within our
national boundaries and this is the
approach we have decided decided to take
I understand that and clearly the Mojave
Desert and indeed Australia are a
different environment but Portugal and
Luxembourg these are places that have
Parable challenges and surely it's
concerning to hear that the
jurisdictions in Portugal and Luxembourg
then landlocked countries quite small
are able to
to adopt more of the the licensing
arrangements from the FAA and that we
were losing out to them and we're taking
a an exceptionalist approach
even compared to those two European
Union countries I'm not familiar with
the the Luxembourg approach but what I
would say is they haven't done a launch
so we will need to wait and see how they
work that through the arsa system and
with geography at the European air
safety agency system
um so we'll need to see and in terms of
Portugal that's not as was covered a
launch capability that's a recovery from
a satellite which is coming in over the
Atlantic Ocean you can imagine the
difficulty of landing something in a
part of you know sea space around the
United Kingdom the challenges that would
that that would bring
um so
um but I don't want to come across as we
have the perfect solution not at all we
are a learning organization this was the
first UK space launch and we have
colleagues in the US that have got over
60 years of this experience this was our
first one
we are learning and improving all of the
the time
in terms of time skills
[Music]
you know how long will this take
um we identified and we publish that for
a first license
uh should be between 9 and 18 months
for that to uh to work through that's
not a you know just taking a swag that
is calculated on the experience of other
safety critical Industries you know oil
gas and the light plus our own
experience as the the CAA and we
published that and that was published in
I think 2019 before the CAA even took on
this responsibility what about the
approach of implementing that we heard
that you can make one application only
and then that's it rather than being
able to iterate it and and work it up as
it were I'll pass that to Tim in a
moment but if I just say that the Virgin
orbital license within that 9 to 18
month window was done in 10 months
so we did it right at the left hand the
end of what we said we would we would do
now that doesn't mean that every
subsequent license or application is 9
to 18 months we build on the experience
that we've got uh we've already got and
it will depend you know if there was
another
um uh application uh we notified another
launch out of uh Spaceport Cornwall then
would say well this is the same as you
did before it's going to be relatively
straightforward process it is markedly
different then well there's more work to
uh to be done and it's not necessarily
that a 9 to 18 month process for every
satellite and again we use proportional
regulation uh here we don't just say
here's a blank a template and applies in
every circumstance we analyze risk we
look at the mitigations and we work with
those that were licensing but uh so on
this point obviously there are lessons
to be to be learned and we've heard that
a kind of you know a single application
needing to be made without the the kind
of the ability to iterate it has been
constraining is that something you can
change
and so the Spaceport and the launch
license licenses that we have issued are
not just for one launch they are for for
Virgin and for Spaceport Cornwall they
allowed two launchers
um two launches a year so they're in
place
um if
either Facebook call a virgin want to
fly a slightly different trajectory
there would be a process involved in
amending the license but it is certainly
not going back to sort of first
principles and applying for a whole new
license that's one I think the
advantages of the UK regime that we for
for launching the point that we heard
was on the way to getting the first
license that there was a sense that they
had to submit everything and then wait
and hope for the best rather than as it
were working up
the the content to be able to get to an
approval and have that kind of iterative
relationship
and I think from our perspective we had
a very iterative relationship both with
Virgin orbit uh and Spaceport Cornwall
um uh we went over regularly to see them
we had multiple meetings most weeks
um most weeks of the Year where they
were submitted evidence we were
assessing it we were asking some
questions we were testing and probing it
so
um as Stephen said uh we're a learning
organization I think we adapted a lot of
our engagement throughout the course of
uh last year and how we went about that
um but I sort of in preparation for this
uh this Committee hearing went back and
looked at the amount of Engagement we
did with all of the applicants and it
was very very considerable okay let me
turn to my colleagues Stephen Metcalf
wanted to come in with something but
thank you uh good morning everyone and
so Stephen you talked about the the
regulatory framework being laid down in
statutes
so
have any degree of flexibility in the
way you interpret that
and the second part of that question is
when deciding how to interpret it what
process do you go through because
obviously everything can't be covered
through legislation you have to decide
what to do
um absolutely it's not a case or and we
would never want it to be the case that
in statute it describes everything that
you must do because
um ultimately if we could I don't know
write a formula or an algorithm and you
just put in the variables and outcome
the answer then you wouldn't need people
involved there has to be judgments uh in
there
and probably the primary judgment is
around as a law is reasonably
practicable
um now the approach to it was reasonably
um from my perspective is you make every
effort to gather the evidence and the
data that is reasonably you're able to
uh to access
that you examine every risk and you work
it through to you know a reasonable
conclusion
and at the end of all of that you can be
satisfied that we've got all the the
data inputs if you like and then you
apply the judgment
the risk is that if you apply the
Judgment too early in the process and
you say well yeah I'm sure this is going
to be okay
well a lot of the times you you that
that might be fine
um but uh when it's not fine then you'll
subsequently go back and and regret it
now as it was covered by previous
Witnesses this space launch is a complex
and demanding activity there are
multiple factors that you need to to
look at so it takes time to go through
that uh that exercise
um but so we need to take it to a
reasonable conclusion if we just waited
till the point where um we had absolute
certainty then we wouldn't be doing as
law as recently uh practical so that's
the way we approach it how does that
work through in in practice is uh we
have you know an excellent space team in
the the CAA they build up all the
evidence and they come to their
judgments and then we have additional
layers
um uh Who oversee their work and
ultimately there is a single accountable
individual in the CAA who are
responsible for signing off and saying
um I'm satisfied the evidence is there
here are the judgments that I have made
and then ultimately within the CAA as a
whole the board does not make that
safety-based decision because it's less
of accountable individuals but the board
makes sure that the cas work has been
done well and that the decisions that
have been made appear reasonable to them
as well so that's how we we work it
through fine thank you thank you that's
very clear
um so what I don't want to do is we've
we heard mentioned earlier of a CCTV
camera in a factory being needing to be
assessed as part of this process but
what you're saying is there must be a
reason for that can you speculate as to
what that reason would be or do you
think that's an overburden you know
somewhere in the middle it's either it's
overburdened some regulation or there is
a really good sensible reason for that
that we don't know
so I think the uh the point was made in
relation to National Security clearances
that is part of the process which is uh
set down and I know there was a question
about what are all the agencies who have
to be involved well we have that listed
if you want to uh to go through it
um I think that in those sorts of areas
absolutely this is where we need to do
lessons identified and say is the
um is it proportional what is being done
in the that security risk assessment I'm
not making a judgment what the outcome
would be but we need to analyze that
I think that those sort of areas
um uh consultation that's a significant
part of the timelines involved here how
and with whom we can consult
um those are things we can work on there
are a number of areas
what I would be very reluctant to do is
to say that we start to compromise on
the safety-based issues because
um these things go wrong I mean
um you know across space operators space
launch overall the success rate
particularly in the early stages is
actually quite low things do go wrong
um and our we are accountable as a CAA
for making sure that when they do go
wrong they go wrong if you like in a
safe way that doesn't affect people on
the ground and cause risk risk to life
so but that's the core if you like
around the outer I think there's much
work to be done and that's why I'm
really looking forward to these lessons
identified uh process thank you very
much thank you thank you Catherine
Fletcher thank you Joe
um uh so Stephen I don't have your
bravery or your background in terms of
your military career in history but what
I was doing before I came into this
place was trying change businesses and
processes and improve things and there
are a number of things that I've heard
that give me some concern I've I've
almost heard it's not awful it's the law
I've heard language and mentality that
perhaps misses the Strategic importance
and intent of the companies that have
been giving evidence to us so
highlighting is a positive thing the
number of meetings that you've had with
an individual around judgment and
proportionality for these commercial
businesses to want to sit in the UK time
is money they want to know if they're
having a meeting with the CAA that it's
fact-based that they understand the
process that they can provide evidence
and have a dialogue as you talk about
and if I'm candid I almost get a sense
of the fact that you don't think it's in
the right place you know it should be in
the Mojave Desert you don't really like
it's very busy airspace you've got a lot
to do
um we're going to allow two launches a
year is that the right strategic intent
from the leadership in the CIA to
support a burgeoning industry
um so Stephen if I start with you but
Tim this really is all in the detail as
you know we both know yeah so I mean if
I've created the impression that um we
are somehow you know been reluctantly
doing that then that is the wrong
impression as I said uh at the start uh
the cea has those two roles you know
core regulatory role um in accordance
with the the statute but a role to
enable a successful thriving Aerospace
Enterprise and we have invested
significantly over that in that over the
last um uh three years uh or so and it
goes beyond space into wider Innovation
areas and Advanced Air mobility and
things like like that so we absolutely
want to play our part I'm not leaning
just into the legislation and say well
we're just it's because of the
legislation uh tells us to and therefore
um but what I am saying is that as the
civil aviation Authority
our Authority comes from the legislation
and uh that is where we are accountable
and so I need to make sure that the
civil aviation Authority is working
within the legislation can you give us a
for instance of a tweak that could be
made to that that would speed up the
process I mean we heard for example the
hazard areas in the sky you know we get
we take a hundred percent approach
whereas others will only designate a
hazard area where a potential piece of
Rocket could land is that in the
legislation
so um I'll ask him to I think the
particular Hazard area that uh Mr Hart
was talking about was a ground-based
seat uh Hazard area based on the size of
the uh the uh the rocket
um say I'll ask him to the detail but my
understanding is that the figure that we
worked on was one which was given to us
by Virgin uh orbital right forgive me is
half has changed legally to make this
process faster if we accept that we want
it to be faster
so I mean it's a really difficult
question in advance of doing the lessons
identified process I think it ties into
the answer I gave earlier I wouldn't go
at the the core safety part of this
because I think that is absolutely
um vital but it is that wider
consultative
um uh the other
um checkpoints that every applicant has
to deal with I think there may be
flexibility uh in in that area uh I
think forgive me I'm just genuinely
going to press you you're a very
articulate man what could you give us
give an example of where we could change
the law to speed this process up not in
terms of implementation of proportional
or an assumption or definition on the
ground of what's practicable is there
anything that stops us doing it faster
in law
I think it is the
um the consultation process
um now I'm not saying that we shouldn't
do a consultation process but I need to
point out that that takes a significant
chunk understanding the consultation
process are in law
uh I believe so I'll just uh check with
uh with Tim yeah particularly
um uh on the environmental assessment uh
and then consult Secretary of State okay
but there are requirements to consult
but the steps of the consultation
because I could consult The Chair by
having a quick word with him in a
corridor or doing a six-month 200-page
process
so I'm just trying to understand is
there any is it mandated what
consultation looks like within law I
think the requirement to consult
um or seek consent for the Secretary of
State as in law as I think we
demonstrated uh last year uh we were
very proportionate in terms of you know
what length of time that those
consultations were yeah well last year
we did we had a bunch of people saying
we're worried about regulations there
being an industry and this year we find
ourselves in receiving the same evidence
so you'll forgive me for being robust
perhaps another way of putting it
um what are you doing to review your
existing licensing process to make sure
that it is fit for purpose what have you
removed from that process
um since December
um so since December we have undertaken
some initial Lessons Learned
conversations with the applicants we are
reviewing our Regulators rules
um uh at the moment which is the answer
is operational level we have got a list
and we're happy to share with you um as
in things that have actually been
removed to make it better the answer is
nothing
we have adjusted some parts of our of
process
um we particularly want to look at
security
and finance as we go forward okay I'd be
very happy the Lessons Learned process
will very happy let's do this a slightly
different way
um what are you doing to look at what
other countries are doing and that
perhaps have a different interpretation
of reasonably practicable or
proportional or you know all of these
kind of words that are incredibly
difficult for engineers and your staff
to Define in a meeting room in Cornwall
and no wonder it's taking ages how on
Earth are they supposed to be able to
Define that what are you doing to speak
to International International Partners
to improve the and steal their ideas if
they're quicker and better
so firstly um I think the um main
relationship we have at the moment is
with the um with the FAA who've got a
sort of a track record
um and actually we've been working uh
with them throughout the whole
um process where we we have been sort of
supporting each other uh through the
licensing
processes and actually we've got
um an ongoing dialogue which I think the
government is helping facilitate with
the FAA about are there some areas where
we could
um put greater Reliance on each other's
um licensing processes uh recognizing
Stephen so conversations dialogue but no
recommendations adopted or practical
actions changed as yet it's practical
practical level we've done lots of
Lessons Learned and we've been able to
say you're probably haven't as a former
businesswoman this does some very civil
servicey where consultations have been
had and chats have been had and
nothing's been delivered I'll pause
there
um uh Tracy actually
um Catherine sort of the question at the
end Ned but so Stephen I just wondered
what recommendations would you like us
to
like us as a consequence
what can we what what recommendations
would make it easier for you to be able
to deliver on what you're being asked to
do
so I think that
um probably
the key one is the one that's been
mentioned particularly by by Mr Hart
because it's been obvious to us as well
is the multivarious agencies that
um license applicants or launch
aspirants wish to or have to engage with
um at that point about some sort of
Central Gateway to help manage that
process I think is is really important
um I mean if it's difficult excuse me
for us as the civil aviation authority
to make all those connections with other
Aviation authorities or
um you know around the the launch area
if it's difficult with us to engage with
a range of government departments then
it's even more so for commercial
entities and it is you know very much so
for a small medium Enterprises and it
might put them off that process so I
think
um that would be the one that would
strike me as a you know a more portal
approach there now we need to be careful
because again I come back to you know
our accountability for safety and we
need to make sure that it doesn't become
a negotiation around around safety you
know the authority has given us to uh to
look after that aspect but I think
that's the one that most uh strikes uh
me I mean I the encouragement to move
faster yeah absolutely you know we want
to move as fast as possible uh as well
um but we are dependent on the evidence
which is given to us
firstly and so there's a responsibility
on on industry
um and then we uh need to make sure that
we have the right level of Engagement
throughout this process and and reassure
um but these things will take time if
we're to get this done properly because
I think it's a you know a vital part of
this I mean we want it to happen quickly
but having a stable predictable
regulatory environment which allows
successful launches
um is an attractive thing in itself we
know it works in aviation is that you
know countries look to the UK as a sort
of Benchmark Nation when it comes to
Aviation regulation and they want to do
their business here as a consequence we
need to create that environment for
space as well and I'd say I'll come back
to the fact that you know 285 licenses
that we've issued uh so far you know
this is a thriving area of activity and
we are growing it constantly in line
with how the sector actually grows
thank you Tracy um Stephen Metcalfe and
finally Rebecca Long baby thank you
chair um good morning I want to move to
the uh UK space agency if I may
um good morning
um
so what role does the UK space agency
play in supporting the UK launch sector
and how long have you been involved in
that
is so in in terms of launch itself then
it's responsible for delivering launch
UK as a program which brings together
both the regulatory elements uh the what
we call the delivery aspects of it as
well as well as brokering the
international agreements that have been
required both Technical and and
otherwise outside of the airspace ones
that have been run which have been run
by DFT and I'm the senior responsible
owner for um for that as a program so I
am I have a strong dependency on
colleagues in the CIA for the regulatory
approach
uh and it's it's been a very good and
strong relationship in developing those
and I would highlight though in terms of
going through this exercise of course
the the first launch there are a lot of
lessons that we'll have to learn we are
on the start of that process today which
is starting to collate the lessons that
the likes of the ca have conducted
bringing them together
um and I would also agree that one of
those early lessons is likely to be the
coordination and the engagement across
different government departments that
customers have to have to face
more more broadly in terms of launching
the role of the UK space agency with
we're there really to do three things
first of all is to catalyze investment
into the sector
um and I wouldn't necessarily agree with
Patrick McCall in terms of saying that
you're having had this one event that
people are then rushing away if I look
at other launch providers when we're
talking about vertical launch in
Scotland
um then we're still seeing inward
Investments and the likes of UK
companies such as orbex who are building
rockets in forests in Scotland have just
closed on a significant investment round
of 40 million pounds and they're taking
on the operation of the Spaceport seeing
they've got 50 people that wouldn't
happen if we hadn't generated the
opportunity and capability to launch in
the UK and similarly we're seeing that
with tax award in Shetland as well where
we're seeing a number of other European
countries that are coming to the UK
because of the regulations that we've
got and because of launch so high
impulse RFA are German companies or
these are people who've chosen to come
to the UK
to do their launch activities or just on
the on that season for me because that's
obviously they're very pertinent to the
evidence that we've heard so you you say
that they're coming because of our
regulations that this reflects
conversations that you've had that they
are positively attracted to our
our regulations compared to other
jurisdictions yeah I mean if I look at
it from another jurisdiction specific
perspective in Europe there are no
others that have regulations enforced to
enable launch at the moment whether it's
the most likely competitors Norway
Sweden and Portugal none of them have
got
um uh primary or secondary legislation
or regulations in place at the moment
that enable them to Launch
it's the so they're attracted by the
fact that we have passed the space
industry action we've got the um the
statute there yes but we we did hear
evidence in our inquiry as you'll
remember in from from multiple companies
who were concerned about the the
regulatory approach
are you saying that there are there are
companies that that will give evidence
to us that actually they think this is
the right approach there are there are
companies that will give a different
version because there are the the only
regulatory environment that they're
aware of is the UK as opposed to
translating from a U.S regulator
environment into a UK particulation
sorry no no that's fine I I think really
I what I wanted to explore a bit more
was the comments that Mr McCall had made
earlier about the damage to the UK
uh space launch sector following uh the
the the events in January
and I is it because
um had the mission been a huge success
would I'm now asking you to put words in
his mouth but would he have been saying
that this was a great you know leave of
to Leap Forward from for the UK space
station because it failed or is it is he
trying to
conflate the two issues of the failure
of the mission or the non-success
perhaps it's a fair aware uh describing
it and the co and the challenges that
the regulatory framework presented I
mean are you right I wouldn't want to
put words into his mouth however
um I I I would observe that
um whilst the outcome wasn't that that
we would obviously want that anybody
would have wanted
actually is continue to demonstrate that
we do have primary legislation that when
secondary legislation that works we do
have regulations and guidance that works
and again it's the very first time that
we've done this so yes there are lessons
but we've proved the system though we've
got a working Spaceport we've got
working regulations we can actually
broker for the Air Sport airspace that's
required for um for launch with our
International colleagues as well so it
can be done it's not to say it can't be
done better and more efficiently but it
can be done there is nobody else in
Europe that can do that at the moment
so you must be working on how we can do
it better and there will be a presumably
a process in place what can the
government do in fact this is my final
question chairman what can the
government do to improve the situation
from where we are now we've got this
working system it's happened but surely
the government could do more
the the and what I'm working on is
reinforcing the success that we've
already got
um and that I think is where we need to
focus our efforts at the moment whether
that be supporting small companies that
want to set up around these spaceports
and generate that income whether it be
being access operating on a global
market
um and as again as a kind of a slighter
side if you look at the number of small
satellites which is what we're focusing
on here so it's small satellite launch
back in 2012 there were some 50 small
satellites launched into space globally
last year there were 1700. it's it's a
it's a rapidly growing market and whilst
the overall space economy is worth
around about 360 billion dollars
globally about 20 billion of that is in
launch but there is a part of that that
is an addressable part for the UK so it
has economic value to the UK if you can
attract in international players to come
and launch in the UK as well as the
point that Melissa was making the the
was there is an element across security
there is an element across knowledge
whether that be through inspiration or
increasing skills and us our space
workers in the UK have over two and a
half times productivity so that's an
economic output as well or indeed
whether it's the prosperity agenda so
that's where we should be focusing on is
is
um catalyzing that investment by helping
these companies to get off the ground
and operate within the UK
I'll just add a really quick factual
point and we've got 38 companies across
the space sector whether that be
launched Spaceport range or satellite
companies who are either in an
application process formally or are in
pre-application discussions with us so I
think that evidences that there are a
range of companies today looking at the
UK and the regulatory framework and
saying we want to engage with that
thank you Jim thank you very much
Rebecca Long Bailey thank you Ian just a
very brief questions to you you
mentioned that your focus now needs to
be on helping companies get off the
ground within the wider space ecosystem
around launch sites but how specifically
will the UK space agency ensure that it
attracts future launch missions and to
Cornwall and other UK spaceports
or we'd be part of that is generating
clusters of activity around the UK and
we're planning over this spending review
period to invest over 70 million pounds
in in doing that
um whether that's attracting very small
activities
um or whether it's indeed some of the
larger aspects that we were announced
yesterday in terms of British companies
being able to compete into Moonlight
which is the ability to provide
Communications around around the Moon as
well so there are a number of activities
that we're doing that have have got
specific funding attached to them and
that will be managing as projects and
programs from within the agency
we've already heard
um to operate launch missions do you
think that the UK is in a situation
where we need to offer subsidies in
these early stages of the of the
emerging market
I I think it's important to look at the
the broader context of that Josh Weston
from space Forge alluded to it
um if he's going to launch from us he
has to send his staff to the US you know
virgin orbit had 50 people over here in
the UK at one point that's a cost to the
company if you don't have to do that if
you can do it from UK that's an
immediate saving to uh to companies as
well and
um I I'd kind of look at it from the
perspective that
um it's not just about regulations or
the cost of launching you come to the UK
because you've got a stable democracy
you've got a stable legal framework
we've got you know more satellites are
insured in the UK than anywhere else
across the globe so you know you come to
the UK for all of those aspects that
create the environment in which you
would want to launch from the UK from
an Ideal World
what would you be asking them to do to
support the space industry and future
launch sites going forward
I mean that's in part a policy question
for the Department to which we're
responsible for in terms of Department
science Innovation and and and
Technology
um
I I'd probably dug that one to to ask
from a from a policy perspective into
the department rather than the agency
our role is to to deliver of course we
would want to generate people with
greater skills more skills so we can
draw on that I think one of the
challenges that we have across the
sector not just within the agencies
bringing the the right number of people
with the right level of skills so
anything that we can do to improve that
which we're also doing within the agency
will of course continue to
feed at the bottom whether it be through
inspiration or Technical Training
thank you Rebecca we have the new
secretary of state for science
Innovation and technology and we hope
that she'll come soon to give evidence
to the committee and we no doubt we'll
ask about space finally for me um
we have two witnesses from the civil
aviation Authority is as the name
implies
um this is principally concerned with
civil aviation which is a huge and very
important sector quite a mature one and
I'm conscious that during the pandemic
and subsequently there have been major
challenges out there
on reflection that the CAA is the rights
host for for this very different
character of activity and if we or the
government were to look again at the the
statutes might it be better to have a
separate focused space regulatory agency
um no I'm not just saying this because
of the role that I'm in at the moment
but I believe it's actually actually
essential that space activity is within
the civil aviation Authority when I was
doing my preparation three years ago for
this role one of my things in my mind
was well why isn't the CAA doing space
as well and then I came across the fact
that this was working through its way
through in legislation why is that
important
um uh that they're joined up in that way
nothing gets to space nothing comes back
from space without going through air
um and so you have all of the
coordination issues in relation to
airspace control
Etc working with other uh International
authorities
um in a uh more practical sense the
skills and capabilities that you need in
relation to doing risk management in
space are the exactly the same ones as
on the air side and so when I talk about
you know there's 50 people in the CAA
Space Team the whole of the CAA
virtually was involved in this space
activity in some way or other lots of
reach into the aviation side
um Mr Hart mentioned that you know in
747 is an experimental 747 and it has to
be certified by the CAA as an aircraft
and the rocket is done in another part
of the ca just all of the organizational
synergies are are clear and so I um I'm
absolutely convinced this is the right
place for it say again that you know
we're not saying that we are perfect but
I think we have got a good framework and
we need to keep building on that and
this point about Pace applies across the
sector I mean I'm sure this committee is
hearing from innovators in relation to
Advanced Air Mobility air taxis Etc
exactly the same issue and we are
working on that right right now in terms
of you know that touch on the touch
points into uh to government and clearly
we speak
um uh more broadly but our sponsoring
department is the department for
transport
um and uh I just would want to say that
we had great support for them throughout
the Virgin orbital process including
support on us uh doing what was
necessary within the timelines which
were advertised to ensure this was a
safe safe launch so we weren't working
in isolation we were working very
closely with our sponsoring department
and across across government and they
were satisfied with what we were doing
well thank you for that that's that's
very clear clearly the kind of context
of today's hearing is that we were very
disappointed to hear
from some of the stakeholders in the
industry about some of their
frustrations about the regulatory
process but it's quite right to say and
to put onto on records that you have an
important safety responsibility and it's
easier in some ways to have this kind of
discussion than a much more difficult
discussion uh if um if people's lives
had been put at risk or worse and so you
do have an important job to do
clearly in such a fast-paced industry
our space we need to keep Pace with the
competition it's been the Strategic
ambition of us to be a leading space
nation and that does impose some
requirements on the pace of change and
innovation in Regulators we're grateful
for your assurance that you're up for
that change and the committee will
reflect on the evidence that we've heard
and make some suggestions to the
government and the agency and other
stakeholders but thank you very much
indeed for your evidence today and for
coming in person and to those other
witnesses that gave evidence earlier
this morning a conclusions meeting the
committee order